[Music]
we've given them legitimacy uh on the
world stage
obviously we're leaving in defeat uh we
rushed we have a fang in the seal teams
don't rush to your death and that's what
we did don't rush to your death don't
rush to your death that means evaluate
the situation take a breath uh make a
good call for the guys that you're
commanding
in this case we had 20 years to prepare
for this moment and we did it about the
worst you could possibly do it let's say
let's give everyone the benefit of the
doubt and say since april we could
prepare
even from april to now we still don't
know how many american citizens were in
the country where they were as city
after city started to fall province
after province started to fall to the
taliban we didn't make any
moves to try to locate american citizens
just in case we might need to evacuate
them just in case the taliban took over
kabul or took over the country and you
can see it as we get into june as we get
into july then as we get into august and
then everybody in the white house goes
on vacation apparently uh and puts auto
replies on their emails and kabul falls
and we've given up strategically
advantageous position to put once again
that e1 that e2 that e3 that junior
officer in the most tactically
disadvantageous position that you
possibly could put them in uh and it was
completely unnecessary if you applied
common sense to the problem well so
that's what this has been my obsession
for the last week as someone i was never
in the boy scouts i don't know anything
about military strategy we should have
given this to the boy scouts but they
don't exist anymore that's kind of the
point i made they don't exist anymore
that's right they were bigots um
the mistakes were so obvious even i can
understand them but they made them
anyway
so then you ask well you know why is
that there's not one or two mistakes or
even a series of mistakes this is like
an uninterrupted chain of mistakes
what do you think drove this well we
call it a snowball effect when you make
when one error turns into multiple
planes crash
exactly that's exactly right um but we
can go back to that to 2001 to start
seeing this snowball take effect and
then it takes up speed here in mid april
until we get to where we are today where
we're leaving apparently there's we left
dogs behind we left american citizens
behind we left all these weapons behind
which that is just below so we've armed
the enemy we've been fighting for the
last 20 years
even though we conflated the enemy
taliban
harboring al-qaeda al-qaeda we kind of
dumped them together we didn't really
understand tribal nature of things how
we change sides and move around we
didn't quite quite get that so we ended
up going to war
to crush al qaeda okay and then we
wanted to degrade i think the exact
wording from the national security team
back in 2001 was that we wanted to
degrade the military capability of the
taliban that's how it started off then
the taliban got conflated with al qaeda
and we started fighting al qaeda and
they became our enemy for the last 20
years
while at the same time we're nation
building by the time but same time we're
shifting focus to another war in the
region that's draining resources from
from afghanistan um so it becomes
this this quagmire this is the best way
to describe it and then we get to what
we're seeing today where we're now
not just elevating them on the world
stage because we had to leave but we're
also arming them and
we are also
recognizing them as a legitimate
government
so
okay they are better armed better
trained and
better
situated on the world stage is legit
than they were before 9 11 which i think
is a hard part for veterans for people
that fought there for people that are
dealing with that emotional and physical
trauma the battlefield that's why these
suicide hotlines are ringing off the
hook right now um because veterans are
looking back and saying wait a sec all
those things that i just said are true
well what did i sacrifice for what's
this what did i give my leg for what's
it what did uh the family of my friend
give their their son or their daughter
for if we just we we just armed this
taliban that i was fighting over there
in 2006 7 89 10 11 12 whenever it was
so i can see how veterans are going to
have a very hard time dealing with this
going forward and what's important is
that they take that rage and they
channel it in a way that moves the ball
forward for the rest of their country
which means not
taking not robbing their family of their
tomorrow because of the horrible
decisions of our seniors
that's exactly right and take that rage
take that and channel it in a positive
direction
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else